Il y a quinze ans à peine
Il y a quinze ans déjà
Ma mémoire est incertaine
Mais mon cœur lui n'oublie pas
Un été de porcelaine
Un cœur pour la première fois
Qui chavire et se déchaîne
Et balbutie ses premiers pas
I have never forgotten
That one summer you were mine
On a lonely beach, hidden
From all people and time
I have never forgotten
When we walked along the shore
One sweet kiss and you promised
To be mine for ever more
Des étés de porcelaine
J'en ai connus après toi
Sans que jamais ne revienne
Le goût que tu leur donnas
Un jour j'ai revu la plage
J'ai retrouvé des enfants
Qui comme nous jouaient à leur âge
Le brouillon de leurs quinze ans
I have never forgotten
That one summer you were mine
On a lonely beach, hidden
From all people and time
I have never forgotten
When we walked along the shore
One sweet kiss and you promised
To be mine for ever more
I have never forgotter
That one summer you were mine
On a lonely beach, hidden
From all people and time
I have never forgotten
When we walked along the shore
One sweet kiss and you promised
To be mine for ever more